think people could Test Now activity
Fitness sleep tracker blood sugar with a
CGM a poop test and then you get a
comprehensive poop test
why do you say that so casually you did
not just look your boy in the eye and
say poop test and nobody cracked a smile
or anything a poop test a poop test
oh yeah yeah not bad yeah yeah yeah no
yeah look at me in the eye say that
don't laugh a CGM tracker [__] hmm what
else
put
a poop test
a fart test
a poo poo pee pee test a dump swamp you
gotta take a turd quiz
dookie exam
what do you think a poop test is just
[__] in the zip lock bag
right into the doctor
you gotta take a look at this
that came out of my ass